with almost 500 sessions on next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see the
high performance Network then stay tuned
because here's the rewind it's no
surprise that Google serves billions of
search query answers and hours of
YouTube videos to users all over the
world but what really powers this
ability is the network that allows us to
replicate content and services globally
and it's also the network that powers
Google Club the big question is how we
built the underlying physical and
operating aspects of this network to
build for resilience let's first talk
about our global physical network over
the last 20 years Google has built an
extensive network connecting continents
using submarine cables in fact one of
our new undersea cables between Sydney
and Singapore has cut network latency in
half
planning and building our own submarine
cables means we can build a level of
path certainty and predictability of
network traffic performance these paths
are private and Google implements this
through our consortium of partners this
means that Google cloud customers are
able to connect to this network at
locations all over the world how do we
plan for resilience we do extensive
simulations when deciding to add new
network capacity and make sure it's not
affecting our SLO s in a negative way we
use trended historical data on outages
and then classify different failure
types across the entire network path and
run them for a fictional 20 30 40 50
years across a range of network paths
this gives us a reasonably high degree
of certainty that the network we choose
and the additional capacity locations
and paths we add will increase the
resilience and the predictability that
would care so much about these
simulations mean we can be sure we are
avoiding any negative impact for Google
cloud customers how do we operate in a
resilient manner we've been operating a
software-defined network across our core
data center network we're now extending
that out to the very edge with the
announcement of espresso a couple of
years ago this enables us to maintain a
level of performance and availability
right out to the edge which isn't
possible using regular routing protocols
and approaches at the edge network we
can connect with nearly all significant
network operators which allows handoff
of network traffic directly and will
to ninety-nine percent of our traffic we
also have Network site reliability teams
stationed around the world their role is
to respond and adapt to network events
to improve systems and processes so
reliability and performance of network
continues to improve over time when an
issue occurs they identify root causes
and implement new workarounds in other
words they're here as first responders
to make sure Google cloud customers have
a consistent and reliable experience now
there's always a risk of bad actors or
network exposure Google is continually
enhancing our own monitoring and
filtering capabilities to get quicker
and better because this is a
community-wide issue we have a new
partnership with manners which is a
mutually agreed norms for routing
security where we are working to enhance
the security of routing on the Internet
if you're wondering about how Google
designed its strong network backbone
we built a software-defined network from
the ground up our first iteration was
before a massive backbone between all of
our data centers we then introduced
Jupiter which is our massive switching
fabric that goes within our data centers
and makes tens of thousands of machines
act together as one big system Andromeda
the network software defined at the
virtualization layer that Google Cloud
customers used to build their cloud
resources and espresso are taking Sdn
capabilities out to the edge all of
these components have helped us scale
and deliver traffic for Google products
like search and YouTube and these are
the same building blocks that Google
Cloud customers get to use - now there
is a ton more they cover in the talks
about the protocols we use to improve
performance our global load balancer
virtual private cloud and logging and
monitoring so check out the full talk in
the link in the description below and
don't forget to subscribe to the cloud
YouTube channel for more great next
rewind content thanks for watching
[Music]